when people want to make women feel small or to shut them up
they will attack their looks
because they believe that a woman's power is solely tied to her appearance
now in some ways they're right
because in the world we live in
beauty absolutely is a currency of power
but the funny thing is
women are taught from a young age not to take ownership of that power
I always think of that one direction song
she don't know she's beautiful
that's what makes her beautiful
because we don't want women to feel or own their power
a woman's beauty and her sexuality actually also should be given to her
or bestowed upon her by the opinions of others
a resource for someone else to yield
after all a beautiful wife is a status symbol for her husband
is it not sorry
I'm rewatching Bridgerton
so I really think that the most powerful thing a beautiful woman can do
is know that she's beautiful
because when your beauty is self defined
it can stop being used as a weapon to be used against you
because truly
in an argument
if somebody starts going after your looks
they've already lost the point anyway
and they're trying to make you feel less powerful
so they can get the upper hand again
after all someone else's opinion on your appearance doesn't matter